[موسيقى]
مساء الخير شاعر وروائيون وناقد خبير في
التراث الثقافي السعودي انتقدت الدائقه
الموسيقيه والغنائيه يراها فاسده له اراء
حاده تجاه المؤسسات الثقافيه والبحثيه من
اهم مؤلفاته سحاره الخليج السعوديه حركات
التجدد والمحرم الخليجي له ايضا العديد من
الدواوين الشريف شاعر وروائي والناقد
الدكتور احمد الواصل في سؤال مباشر حياك
الله يا دكتور مساء الخير
على شاشه العربيه حياكم الله أبدا معك من
تغريده لك تقول فيها عندما تعتاد الاجيال
على قبول الفاسد في الفن والادب وليس
الرديم فتكون معيار ضائقه التورته الى
اللاحق حتى اذا اختلف منهم وانفضح الفساد
تشنج المدافعون عن قضيه خاسره واستقوى
المختلف حتى يردم الماضي واهله
ايش قصد فيها الكلام اول شيء وش فرق
الفاسد عن الرديء في الفيلم
طبعا عندنا احنا معي في النقده معايير
الجميل والجليل او القبيح طبعا
حتى معيار الجوده والرداءه موجود هو من
مصطلحات النقديه لكن خارج المصطلحين ندخل
في امر بعيد تماما عن
المفهوم
الثقافي سواء كان فن او ادب وبالتالي
دائما مؤسسات التربويه والتعليميه
والاكاديميه تحاول ان تقدم المعيار سواء
للطلبه اللي يدرسون متلقين او حتى من يمكن
ان يكونوا اصحاب مواهب ثم يعني يبدعون في
مجالات الثقافه سواء الفن والادب او الفكر
فبالتالي يمكن ان يغيب وجود المؤسسه
التربويه وبالتالي هذا
يخل في المعيار في المجتمع بشكل عام مما
يجعل ان الفاسد الداخل مع الرديء حتى يكاد
الاثنين يكونون
في الفن الاولاد طبعا هو كل ما يخالف
المعايير الفنيه الاساسيه سواء في القواعد
او في العناصر الفاسد هو الذي يعني يمنع
وجود الاخر الفاسد هو الذي يمارس نوع من
العنف اللفظي او المعنوي لوجود الاخر في
الفن والادب طبعا الذي يستخدم ايضا او
يتقوى بعناصر او
بنقول ادوات داعمه من اجل القضاء على
الجميل ايضا في الفنون والاداب وهذا يحدث
اوقات لمصالح ودوافع مختلفه طبعا وهذا
طبعا ينعكس فيما بعد على المتلقين فتخيل
جيل جيلين ثلاثه اربعه يتعودون على الفساد
في مفهومهم مثلا مثلا فن الرسم فن الغناء
فن تمثيل فبالتالي يعتقدونهم هذا الفاسد
هو المعيار وبالتالي يمتنع عليهم فرصه
التعرف على الاصول تعتقد اليوم اصبح معيار
الدائقه هو الفساد في الفم زي ما تقول
اولده
لا الفساد عارض او طارئ لا يمكن ان يكون
نظام على الاطلاق نهائي هو ما نسميه احنا
يعني نظريا فوضى وبالتالي هو عاده ياتي في
فترات الفجوات العصريه او فتى فترات
الفراغ ياتي يعني ولا شك طبعا يعبر عن
ايضا مفهوم حتى المؤامره ايضا هناك يعني
لا يمنع انه ممكن يكون هو ايضا يستخدم
للمؤامره لكن هو طارئ لا يمكن ان يكون
نظام ولا يمكن ان يكون اعتياد
اليوم كيف تشوف انت مستوى الدائقه الفنيه
في في العالم العربي في الخليج في
السعوديه يعني تختلف المساله
نعم ما في شك
الاساليب الفنيه الاساليب الادبيه
التيارات بشكل عام المبدعين عددهم تمركزهم
الوسائل التي تخدمهم وسائل عرضهم هذه كلها
طبعا تشكل ذائقه مجتمع في فتره معينه في
مرحله معينه عبر وسائل ايضا معينه ما في
شك طبعا
وممكن ايضا هذه تجني على المجتمع يعني اذا
عودناهم على
الجمال الداعم او على الاقل اذا كثر او
بالغنا فيه يتحول الى عبء عبء جمالي يعني
فيصير في مشكله ايضا في تقبل اي حركه
جديده فيما بعد يعني يصير في صعوبه في
تقبل حتى المختلف المختلف حتى بالزمن او
بالجيل يصير في ايضا حتى صعوبه في تقديم
النفس يعني المبدع الجديد كيف يقدم نفسه
المبدعه الجديده كيف تقدم نفسها يعني ممكن
يكون عبء عاده التوازن بالامور هذه تاخذ
فتره بعد ما تنتهي
حاله الضجيج او حاله المعاصره ترشح الامور
فتتضح الرؤيه هذه
مرتبه اليوم عند الجمهور خلينا نتكلم عن
الخليج مثلا بشكل خاص يعني
الدائقه الفنيه بشكل عام يعني وين تضعها
في اي مستوى يعني مستوى عالي مستوى متوسط
اقل ولا شلون شايف اعتبرها مستوى عالي
نسبه بسيط جدا
هل بسيط هذا هو اساسي الثقافه العربيه
يعني من اهم
منتجاتها الثقافيه الشعر
والفنون والاداب كلها قائمه على النص يعني
حتى نكاد احنا من باب المبالغه طبعا هذا
وليس حقيقه طبعا انه نقول انه كل فروع
الادب من الشعر لكن الاغنيه تقوم على
الشعر ايضا حتى التمثيل سواء مسرح شعري او
حتى كتابه شعريه حتى في الدراما طبعا يعني
او حتى دراما الاذاعيه او التلفزيونيه
ذاق الشعريه اعتقد انها هي الصمام الامان
في المجتمعات العربيه
وهي دائما النقطه او المفتاح الاساسي
عندما يتلقون الاغنيه يبحثون او يركزون
على النص
فيما بعد حسب خبرات الشخص الفرديه
قد يعني يتذوق اللحن صوت الاداء الالات
الامور الاخرى التقنيه ايضا لكن الشعر
العربي ما زال حتى الان واعتقد انه
ما خان المجتمع العربي نهائيا بالتالي
بناء على هذا الراي تعتقد انه دائقه
المجتمعات الخليجيه واللي تشمل حتى
الدائقه الفنيه الغنائيه الادبيه اصبحت في
مستوى عالي عكس من يتحدث عن الزمن الجميل
عشان كده يمكن انت كتبت المقوله او مقال
سميته اكذوبه الزمن الجميل قلت فيه تمت
عبارات تتخذ من نفسها مسطره او مش جبل
معياريا في عالم الانتاج الثقافي ضمن مسار
التباكي او المناحه على زمن باتا من
الماضي لا يذكر منه الا ما يراد لا جميع
ما حدث مقابل حاضر
يعجز عن رؤيته بعين
يومين انت ما تشوف انه في فن او زمن جميل
اولا
لا الذاكره
مخادعه
تحفظ في ذهنك ما تريد وتنسيك ما تريد
وبالتالي
يتحكم ايضا خبرات العاطفيه والذهنيه عند
الانسان
ترتبط اوقات يعني علاقته بالفنون والاداب
بمراحل حياته السعيده والحزينه والمفرحه
وتم متفائله ايضا الكئيبه والمنهزمه
ومنها هنا يبني مفهومه للزمن الجميل
يعني في كل زمن في كل تقريبا الجميل وايضا
الفاسد
الجميل الجميل هو القبيح هو وجه اخر من
جميل مقبول لكن ايضا يوجد الفاسد وتوجد
الاخطاء موجوده في كل فتره يعني لكن ذاكره
تسمح لك فقط ان تنظر الى ما تريد ان تذكره
وهو الجميل فقط وبالتالي عندما تواجه في
فتره المعاصره كل الانواع المختلفه تتوقع
انه الماضي هو الافضل بينما انت تتذكر
الافضل من الماضي فقط وفي المساله يعني
ذهنيه نفسيه ترتبط بمجتمع معين ولا هي
موجوده في كل المجتمعات يعني مساله الحنين
موجود في كل المجتمعات يعني انه انه
الانسان سفار وبالتالي لما يسافر ينقل معه
ما يهمه
او تاخرها او ثقافه مجتمع او مدري ايش
يعني ولا لا هناك تلازم بين ما نسميه حنا
ثقافات الشعوب وحضارات الشعوب ثقافات في
الغالب في الغالب هي تكون مرتبطه بالجانب
المعنوي الحضارات مرتبطه بالجوانب الماديه
وبالتالي
توهمنا انه في توازي بينهم لكن هناك ممكن
تاخر او مسارات مختلفه ثقافه مسارها دائ
وليس خط طولي العكس الحضاره الحضاره تتغير
الصناعات والتقنيات تتبدل ممكن تقف فجاه
صناعه وياتي بدالها تقنيه لكن الثقافات لا
هي عمليه فرز للعناصر في كل فتره تفرز
العناصر في عناصر يستفاد منها في هذا
العصر بينما في عصر اخر تهمل من حق الناس
تسمي هذا الجمل اللي كان فيه او الزمن
اللي كان فيه عظماء الفن كلثوم عبد الحليم
فريد عبد الوهاب وغيرها من الفنانين
المرحوم عبد الكريم عبد القادر طلال
وغيرهم انه زمن جميل لما يكون في نجيب
محفوظ لما تكون في روايات عظيمه في افلام
عظيمه زي الحرافيش وغيرها هذا زمن جميل
فمن الناس من حقها كمان انه يعني
ابواقها تختلف بين مثلا احمد وبين غيره
يعني ليش ننكر انه انه موجود يعني هذا
الزمن يعني من ذكرتهم ما هم اجيال مختلفه
وفترات لمعاتهم
الفنيه مختلفه ايضا يعني مثلا راح انا
اقول فيما يخص السيده ام كلثوم الناس لا
تعرف من ام كلثوم الا فقط اغانيها المصوره
تلفزيونيه وهذه اخر عشر سنوات تعتبر ام
كلثوم دخلت في مرحله متقدمه جدا من عمرها
حتى من صوتها طبعا بينما اذا
نحن نقضيه التاريخيه فيما يخص ام كلثوم
اهميه ام كلثوم في الثلاثينات والاربعينات
والحان من ملحنين ليسوا استمروا معها في
اخر عشر سنوات يعني من بين بعد 63 ميلادي
حتى
الناس تاخذ كل التفاصيل هذه عن تاريخ فنان
تكلم عن الجمله الموسيقيه الكلمه الحلوه
اللي كانت موجوده في ذاك الزمن الجمله
الموسيقيه زي ما ذكرت الروايه العظيمه
اللي كانت موجوده الفيلم اللي كان موجود
فيه المسلسل وغير يعني في زمن مختلف يمكن
حتى مرتبط حتى مش قيمه فن لازم يكون في
التئام بين الاثنين الزمن والفن يعني انه
هو ضمن بيئه اجتماعيه واقتصاديه وثقافيه
من حق الناس في كتابات مثلا في فتره ام
كلثوم وعبد الوهاب تشن عليهم
وتمدح الزمن الجميل تقصد الزمن اللي هو في
القرن التاسع عشر برضو حلو يعني بالتالي
هنا رجعنا لسالفه اختياريه انتقائيه وهذا
خطر طبعا ذاكره لكن هي تشكل الذوق الشخصي
هذا امر لا علاقه له بالدراسه التاريخيه
او النقديه يعني لا لا علاقه هذه هي
الحقبه الذهبيه للفن والادب في العالم
العربي لا مرينا بحقب كثيره في اكثر من
يعني 1500 عام في كذا حقبه عندنا اذا
بنتكلم على مثلا انه واحد الثقافي يعني
الزمن الجميل الجيل اللي راح يعني هنا بس
خلينا ما نطلع انت ما تعتقد انه هذه تعتبر
حقبه
ذهبيه اكثر من الوقت الحالي اللي شفنا
نشوف فيه اغاني اي كلام
يعني من الصعبه الكلام لاني لا يمكن اسمح
لنفسي اهضم حق للموجودين الان واللي الان
عندهم فاعليه عاليه جدا في انتاجهم الفني
والادبي لانه بعد عشره سنوات ممكن نقول
كلام ثاني لو التقينا يعني فبنقول ممكن
كلام ثاني يمكن يطلع للان احنا يمكن
نغمض حقه في مقابل نعله من الشائن السابق
انه نفس القصه يعني نكرر نفس المساله يعني
لكن في كل فتره هناك جميل في كل فتره في
زمن جميل يعني متى تعتقد انه معيار الادب
والفن كان اكثر رصانه كان بعيد مثلا عن
السمات التجاريه والسريعه اكثر من ما هو
موجود حاليا اللي تغير فيه الزمن دخلت فيه
الماده بشكل كبير شوهت كثير من
اللائقه حتى الفنيه للناس الفنون والاداب
تقوم على مؤسستين دائما هي وحده مؤسسه
معنويه وفي مؤسسه ماديه
ولا تقوم للفنون ابدا ولا الاداب قائمه
الا بهالمؤسستين الجانب التجاري له علاقه
بمساله اسمها الاستهلاك اللي هو فائض
انتاج هذه مساله يمكن
لا يعني يعبا فيها الا الاشخاص اللي مثلا
يحسبون بالارقام طبعا الربح والخساره يعني
او التلف في لكن احنا معيارنا لا يهتم
بالامور هذه يعني عشان كذا راح ارجع
للقضيه الانتقائيه انه احنا ننتقل يعني
انت ممكن تجد انه كلثوم هي المهمه لكن
تاريخيا هناك فتحيه احمد لوردكاش هناك
ماري جبران هناك نادره امين في اكثر من
شخصيه
نفس القفه في ما يخص عبد الحليم ايضا هناك
محرم فؤاد ومحمد رشدي وفي شفيق جلال وفيه
كارم محمود في مجموعه نفس الشيء فيما يخص
محمد عبد الوهاب ايضا كان في فتره يعني
ايضا اسماء اخرى يعني فبالتالي من الصعب
انا انه اختصر جيل في شخص لكن انا ما اقدر
امنع انه حب الناس يخص عبد الحليم حافظ ما
يقدر نمنعه راح نتحول الى موضوع الموقع
الاغنيه الخليجيه والسعوديه هو محور
حديثنا في الجزء الثاني فاصل ونعود
مشاهدينا الكرام للمتابعه بسؤال مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد ضيفي هو الناقد والشاعر
الدكتور احمد الواصل حياك الله دكتور احمد
اهلا وسهلا بسالك عن الاغنيه السعوديه
والخليجيه كتب كثير في هذا الموضوع
احمد الواصل كيف يؤرخ اول شيء الاغنيه
السعودي
كيف
سريع عندنا خلينا ناخذها في مراحل احنا
نعرق بشكل عام الغناء العربي
بالوثائق الوثائق يا اما تدوينات مكتوبه
يعني او نقول تسجيلات صوتيه
لم يتيح لنا تسجيل الصوتي الا في القرن
العشرين ومن هنا صار في فرصه لحفظ الصوت
البشري بالاضافه طبعا الى حفظ ايضا صوت
العزف
وتقنيه التسجيل المختلفه طبعا بدايه يعني
من اشكال الاستوديو
واشكال الحفظ والاسطوانات الشمعيه والحجر
وما الى ذلك يعني حتى تطورها يعني الى
الان الى الام بي ثري يعني او التقنيات
اللي بتوفر التسجيلات الصوتيه وما غيرها
فبالتالي الاغنيه مربوطه بالوثيقه الصوتيه
من دونها لا مثل التمثيل من دون موسيقى
بصريه لا نعرف من كان يمثل او كيف كان
يمثل نفس الشيء من كان يغني وكيف كان يغني
يعني مثلا كتاب او الكتب اللي دونات
الغناء العربي الكثيره يعني طبعا اشهرها
عند الناس اللي هو كتاب الاغاني للاصحاني
وفي كتب اخرى طبعا فيما بعده استمرت بنفس
الطريقه للتدوين نحن نقرا نصوص ونقرا وصف
لكن لا نسمع اصوات
ولا نسمع اصوات الات فقط نقرا النصوص
القرن العشرين اتاح لنا وثائق صوتيه
وهذه بدايه الاسطوانات
والتسجيلات طبعا بالاضافه الى طبعا
الوسائل الاخرى عالميه مهمه ايضا الاذاعات
الاهليه لفترتها يعني بعد الحرب العالميه
الاولى قبل كل اذاعات رسميه طبعا الامر
الثاني ايضا ظهرت شركات الانتاج المختلفه
اللي ساهمت طبعا بالاضافه الى مؤسسات
حكوميه ايضا ساهمت الاغنيه السعوديه
الاغنيه هذا مصطلح طبعا لا يعادل كلمه
الغناء الغناء هذا مصطلح اخر الاغنيه
السعوديه نقول اورخت من رحله طارق عبد
الحكيم الى القاهره في منتصف مؤسسه
الخمسينات انه هو من فكر في وضع ما يسمى
بالاغنيه السعوديه
للمعيار اللي كان منتشر من مركزين احنا في
بدايه القرن العشرين بالذات يعني في مرحله
العشرينات والثلاثينات بغداد والقاهره هم
الاولاني فيما بعد تزعم المركزين في
الستينات بيروت والكويت
استفاد طارق انه مركز القاهره كان جاهز
تجهيزاته طبعا وامكانياته والعازفين ولانه
هو بحكم انه يشتغل في المجال العسكري لا
يمكن ان يسجل بصوته فاستعان باصوات
السيدات المغنيات العربيات في القاهره
وبدات هنا ولاده الاغنيه
او خمسه وخمسين مع اصوات نجاح سلام وفايزه
احمد يعني بعدين حدث تغيير سياسي انتقلوا
للتسجيل في بيروت وايضا استمر يسجل مع
المغنين اللبنانيين والمغنيات وديع الصافي
وصباح وسميره توفيق
ومشى في قطاع طبعا مجموعه في منهم من
استطاع ان يسافر مثل طعام مداح
وفي منهم انتظر حتى ظهور الاذاعات
السعوديه وسجل فيها طبعا يعني
ومن هنا استمرت يعني فالاسس اللي وضعها
طارق بما فيها طبعا تاسيسه لما يسمى مدرسه
موسيقات الجيش العربي السعودي اللي هي
يعني كانت مسؤوله من اجل تاسيس فرقه
موسيقى عسكريه في السعوديه
واللي هي طبعا كانت نواه الفرقه الموسيقيه
في الاذاعه مع كوادر اخرى من الدول
العربيه
فطارق هو اوبل اغنيه سعوديه يعني
انقلب عليه بسرعه يعني
صنعت من ملحنين طبعا الملحنين هم اللي
يقدمون اشكال بالاضافه طبعا انه الشعراء
ايضا الشعراء اسهموا بشكل كبير ما في شك
يمكن طارق يعتمد على شاعرين اثنين محمد
الفهد العيسى الفهد وابراهيم خفاجي لكن
مثلا عبد الله محمد اعتمد على شعراء اخرين
فوزي محسون طبعا بعدين لحقهم طالما مداح
عبد القادر حلواني
بعدهم على طول كلهم لاحقوا كل مغني في نفس
الزمن
ينشا لا محمد
محمد
في
الكره كطفل بس نتكلم احنا كمحترف كشعب
محترف يغني اغاني عاطفيه خاصه فيه طبعا
يعني اعتقد انها على منتصف الستينات لكن
يعني صوته حتى ما ركز الا فيما بعد وكلهم
اللي بدون بشكل مبكر يحتاجون وقت حتى تركز
اصواتهم تثبت يعني مسائل يعني تخص طبيعه
الصوت البيولوجيه طبعا فكل واحد اسهم ما
في شك صار عند كل واحد مجموعه شعراء
ملحنين بنوا اشكالهم كل واحد بنا اشكال
بالاضافه لانه في ميزه هنا عند الاغنيه
السعوديه ومهمه طبعا في المرحله الخليجيه
الاغنيه الخليجيه نخدم المصطلح هذا لانه
مرتبط
بتعبير سياسي له علاقه بتاسيس مجلس
التعاون طبعا برغم انه اللي اسهمه فيما
يسمى باللغه الخليجيه يمكن
كوادر يعني محدوده او متمركزه في السعوديه
والكويت لم تكن الكوادر الاخرى تسهم الا
يعني اما تذهب الى الكويت او تذهب عن طريق
الكويت الى مصر مثل البحرين او او اللي
عرفت في بلدها زي قطر يعني او كذا لكن
عمان والامارات تاخر اسهامها في الاغنيه
الخليجيه باختلاف التراث بينها وبين الدول
الاخرى الاربعه طبعا لكن الاغنيه السعوديه
نقول تاسست بنصف الخمسينات
الاغنيه السعوديه عاشت بجناح واحد طول
فتره عمرها حتى الان هي لا زالت تعيش
بجناح واحد فقط الجناح اللي هو المادي
اللي احنا نسميه المؤسسات الماديه توفر
لها فرصه مؤسسات انتاج خدمات انتاجيه ايضا
خدمات تسويقيه
خدمات ترويجيه العلاقه زي بالحفلات يعني
وهيئه الترفيه هذه نتائج التراكم لكن حرمت
او ربما الاغنيه السعوديه هي حرمت نفسها
يعني كيف حرمت نفسها حرمت من الجناح
الثاني اللي هو مؤسسات التنشئه اللي هو
الاعتراف الاكاديمي التربوي دخولها من باب
من بوابه التعليم تنشئه التدريب لا زلت
الحقبه اللي كان فيها مثلا مؤسسه الدينيه
هي المسيطره مثلا على
خلينا نقول من يضع ارتبط واستراتيجيه
التعليم لم يكن في ذهنهم ذكل فتره
يبرمجون في المناهج وجود مواد خاصه
بالفنون كلها سواء يعني المسرح او
الغناء او العزف طبعا يعني داخل مناهج
التعليم العام يعني
هذا يمهد فيما بعد المعاهد او الكليات
المتخصصه يعني للان ننتظرها تعمل حتى الان
يعني لكن مؤسسه او المدرسه موسيقات الجيش
اللي اشتغلت ما بين الخمسينات حتى وتوقفت
في اول السبعينات
حيث تدرس الات نفخ والات نقر لكن الموسيقى
العسكريه لا علاقه لها بالغناء العربي هي
تؤدي فقط انماط معينه لها علاقه
بالاستقبال والتوديع مسائل دبلوماسيه
وسياسيه طبعا لكن هي لا يقوم عليها لعب
لتطوير او تنشئه واليوم
مع وجود هيئه الترفيه مع وجود برامج
وهيئات الموسيقى هيئه للثقافه الادب
وغيرها من الامه شو اللي تغير كيف ممكن
ننظر الى مستقبل الاغنيه السعوديه
يعني الخبره اللي اكتسبتها الاغنيه
السعوديه من خلال مسائل تجربتها الانتاجيه
العميقه وتعدد شركات الانتاج بالاضافه الى
انه الشركات الانتاج السعوديه استطاعت ان
تضم حتى اصوات عربيه والدليل نرى الان
هيئه الترفيه تستطيع انها تستضيف
ليالي مخصصه حتى الفنانين غير سعوديين
يعني مثل الليالي تكريم لبعض الملحنين
العرب او المغنيين العرب طبعا وهذا
استمرار للتراكم اللي اكتسبته لكن ننتظر
مثلا انا او غيري
الكثير ننتظر مثلا ماذا يمكن ان تفعل
القطاعات التعليميه سواء التعليم عام او
تعليم عالي ماذا ستقدم من برامج متخصصه هل
ستعيد اخطاء برامج التعليم في العالم
العربي والعالم ايضا الاخر او السعوديه
بالفتره اللي كانوا يعاني فيها الفنانين
من المضايقات من فتاوى التحريم
برايك ابدا كانت اخصم فتره في الانتاج
وفتره يعني اوقف كان هناك تميز انك ترى
جمالا
زمن الجميل ممكن تقول انها كان زمن ذهبي
الاغنيه السعوديه لانه هو مركزها تجاريا
ونشرها بشكل جيد لانه الكسر لو دور كان
يمكن في الانتشار اكثر من الاسطوانه
الاسطوانه للاسف معرضه بالتنقل للكسر
الكسر ممكن تعطي ترخيص في دول اخرى وتطبعه
من جديد ما كان هذا متوفر حتى الكاتريج ما
كان متوفر في الاجهزه تشغيله الا سيارات
معينه تعتقد حتى اجهزه معينه لما ظهر
باعتباره بديل بعد الاسطوانات لكن الكاسيت
لا اعطى فرصه اقدر اقول ان المرحله
الثالثه من الاغنيه السعوديه كانت هي بنت
الكاسيت واعطاها فرصه
انتشار كبير هذا ما في شك بالاضافه لانه
ظهر جيل مهم في الثمانينات الملحنين
وشعراء وفنانين مثلا
في فصل مخصص عن محمد عبده في الكتاب
الثالث
الانتاج نفسه الثقافي ايا كان روايه اغنيه
شعر ديوان هو قضيه مو الفنان في بعض
الفنانين اهميتهم تكون في عشر سنين في
عشرين سنه وممكن يعيش فتره طويله بلا شيء
بلا قيمه لكن في ناس مثلا يعني ممكن نقول
هذه العباره احنا بكل بساطه في بعض
الفنانين يكون عايشين موجودين ويعيشون
حاله اعاده تدوير فما يقدمه ما له قيمه
وممكن 20 سنه يقعد وفي ناس يمرون بهذا
الظرف يعني لكن هذا انا ماني معني فيه
نقديا انت ما انت من
يتحسبوا مع فنان ضد فنان
احنا ممكن نتحذب رياضيا بس بالفن والادب
ليش احرم نفسي
أناوي او غيره لانه هذا اللي حصل يعني
هذا التنافس يعني لا الفساد هنا في فهم
اتاحه فرصه للذائقه انها تتلقى الاعمال
عند كذا اسم طيب اذا انت تلقيت عند مثلا
عند طلال مداح او عندك محمد عبده طيب هلا
عشان غازي عليه توقف عن الغناء
بالثمانينات انه هو ما يسمح انه اسمعه او
مثلا جميل محمود توكل وهم كلهم جيل واحد
اصلا هذولا يعني لكن توقف الواحد يمكن ما
عاد عنده شيء يقدم لكن اعماله لا يمكن
تجاهلها يعني
بينما اقول لك في ناس تستمر فتره طويله
بلا شيء جديد يعني مجرد بس يعني اثبات
حضور لا اكثر وهذه مساله يعني قرارها شخص
مو المتلقي يعني القرار ما لنا علاقه فيه
احنا نشكرك شكر جزيل وقت حوارنا وكان ودنا
يزود اكثر لانه نقاط
والمحاور فشكرا جزيلا لك الشاعر والناقد
الدكتور احمد الواصل شكرا شكرا لكم
من سؤال مباشر دائما يمكنكم متابعتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك
يوتيوب ومشاهده هذه الحلقه والاستماع
اليها على شاهد وعلى العربيه
[موسيقى]